a protest over euthanizing homeless pets
thanks for joining us at 11 I'm Denise
Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus now earlier
this week we told you about the number
of dogs being put down at the animal
foundation it nearly doubled from 2021
to 2022. now some of the community
demanding answers as to why this is
happening 8 news now reporter Sasha
Loftus with more
applying to the community strong words
stirring
at the animal foundation
from a group pushing for change this
organization has to stop killing our
animals event leader John on B speaking
on a rise in euthanasia rates according
to the animal foundation's website the
number of dogs put down from 2021 to
2022 Rose 91 percent while intake rates
went up 8 percent cat euthanasia also
spiked 61 percent in the same time
period we need to make sure that we are
taking care of our animals in the city
city councilwoman Victoria Seaman who
also attended the protest says she hopes
to see more action from local leaders
and the community right now our rescues
are at capacity and we have many animals
running freely in the street when we
reached out to the animal foundation
about euthanasia rates this week they
sent a statement reading in part as an
organizational policy only animals not
considered to be healthy and or
treatable are candidates for Humane
euthanasia euthanasia rates vary
depending on the population of animals
we serve I wouldn't bring a dog here but
John says he still wants more answers
and tells us he'll always keep
advocating for animals who need help and
as a pet parent
that breaks my heart Sasha Loftus 8 News
Now
now during tonight's protest Sasha spoke
to several people who claim they tried
to surrender Strays at the animal
foundation but they were turned away now
when she reached out to the animal
foundation to verify this they said
anyone turning in astray or surrendering
needs to make an appointment but right
now those appointments are running weeks
in advance